hey are you happy with your current
lifestyle and where it is taking you
think about this who are you really
and what kind of person do you want to
be
if you want to improve yourself and be
the best
version of yourself then it starts with
a healthy
lifestyle and you need to know that a
healthy lifestyle is not just about
eating healthy and working out but it's
about what's going on
in your mind so in this video i'm going
to show you
how to start a real healthy lifestyle
let's get to it
i
[Music]
[Music]
hey guys if you're new here please
subscribe and also click that
notification bell so you won't miss any
of the next videos
we do style fitness grooming and we talk
a little bit about
life itself i'm daniel and welcome
to dla model lifestyle now there are
five
basic things that you need to do to live
a healthy lifestyle let's start with the
first one
[Music]
set your goals before you do anything
you need to have strong
goals that will motivate you to have
purpose
you need to get your head right first
before you can start
a healthy lifestyle to have a purpose
driven life there are many people on
this planet breathing
but there are not many people who really
live
life how do you do it how do you really
live
life you do it with having purpose
and passion in whatever you do what is
your passion
what is your drive what is your goals
in life write them down small goals
big goals write them all down and then
start to work for them
every single day you will never achieve
your goals by just
wishing for it or just say i'm just
going to stay positive
you achieve them by doing the work
nobody's going to do it for you you need
to work for it
and make it happen and don't say ah i'm
going to do
it tomorrow no start today
you gotta prioritize and cut the fat
the fat i'm not talking here about your
physical body
i'm talking about all those things that
stops you that prevents you from
achieving
your goals bad habits like wasting too
much
time on the couch watching movies or
spending too much time on social media
or playing games
sleeping too long or spending time with
the wrong people
make a list of all the things that you
need to do to achieve
your goals and then prioritize it from
the most important to the least
important things
and you need to know that there will
always be things that you would need to
sacrifice
to achieve your goals for example if you
want to be a great
musician it takes hard work so you need
to sacrifice some of the times that you
would spend with your friends
hanging out you need to sacrifice that
time
and use it to practice if you start your
week
think about your goals think about what
you need to do to achieve them
and then prioritize them prioritize
those things
over other things that you can do at a
later time
you need to start planning ahead because
if you don't plan ahead
you're planning to fail
[Music]
get enough sleep you won't be able to
give your best in everything you do
if you are tired all the time we already
know from all the research that's been
done on it that if you don't sleep
enough
it leads to bad concentration and
alertness so get enough sleep six to
eight hours should be fine
for me i'm at my best if i have seven
hours sleep that's the sweet spot
for some guys it might be eight for some
it might be six
but don't go less than that because less
than that will give you problems
[Music]
eat healthy look you don't need to go on
a big
diet most people don't like big diets
and especially if they're not
used to it so how do you do this then
how do you eat
healthy you start to eat healthy by
choosing the right portion
sizes and also the right type of food
start by substituting all those
unhealthy food
in your kitchen with more healthier
options
for example a whole wheat bread instead
of white bread honey instead of sugar
olive oil instead of normal frying oil
100
juice instead of sodas coffee or tea
instead of hot chocolate
and instead of eating sweets all the
time choose healthier snacks
like dried fruits nuts and beef jerky
choose whole wheat pasta instead of
normal white pasta
cottage cheese instead of normal cheese
and so forth and very
important always choose whole foods over
unhealthy processed food junk
now eating healthy does not mean you
have to eat food that doesn't taste good
just make a list of all the healthy food
that you do like
that is delicious for you and then eat
that my favorite for example is beef
jerky smoothies barbecue mixed nuts
all kinds of fruit especially berries
and lean patties for healthy
burgers seafood and different coffee
flavors from around the world
if you eat healthy food that you like
then it's easier
to live a healthy lifestyle it will give
you a lot more energy
it'll keep the doctors away and your
brain
will be sharp
be more active get out there let your
body work a little bit get moving
according to statista less than a
quarter of u.s
adults get enough exercise and the who
warns that 80 percent of all adolescents
aren't active enough now most of you
already know
that exercise is good for you and why it
is not good for you if you don't
exercise
enough but let me just remind you of
some of the basics
it helps you to control your weight it
improves your mood
boosts your energy helps you to sleep
faster and deeper
and it protects you from diseases or
health conditions
and it even helps with depression and
anxiety
look if you're not happy with the way
that you look
then do something about it you have the
power
to change your body and it is important
to be
happy to be content with the way
that you look go to the gym and work out
at least three to four days a week
it will change your life if you don't
like the gym
do home workouts or start jogging or
even better do
sport like swimming cycling tennis golf
or any other sport just get active try
all kinds of sports until you find
something that you like
you will never know if you don't try
now remember you only have one life
here on earth don't waste it stick
around
check out some of my other videos and
i'll see you there cheers guys